juu say that your father prepared you
yeah as a young child he prepared you
for a life in a horror film what yeah
unexpectedly he did I mean my dad had
this thing on Friday nights whenever he
would be looking after us we called it
Friday night frights and me and my
sister we would be like watching a kids
movie or something and all of a sudden
dad would disappear be watching the
movie and everything would go suddenly
black in the house and you go to the
mains power at the house and switch it
off so we would like cling to each other
thinking and would run around trying to
switch the lights on turn the tv back on
nothing would work we'd call out we'd go
we always sneak through the house and
then all of a sudden he would just come
on hands and knees like a wild boar and
he had come straight for us
and scared the living crap out of us now
my dad thought this was funny you grew
up in a very troubled home I did that
everything you're telling the story
everyone's like this is horrible
you're gonna do that to her kids yeah
well I we started to request this though
like it became al kind of I guess our
amusement I grew up in New Zealand not
much going on at the time and and yeah
so became al kind of Al Friday night fun
yeah that's sad he prepared me for a
life in horror movie no your dad sounds
like a horrible man